[Music]
the blade runner franchise will be
getting new content soon
after the highly acclaimed blade runner
2049 as well as the 1982
classic and three short films a
dedicated anime series is coming soon it
has been known for years that black
lotus is definitely coming though an
initial batch of voice actors has
finally been announced for the anime
as you would expect from a true anime
there's of course a japanese voice cast
list
but for the sake of convenience and
above all familiarity
we will only cover the us dubbing
featured will be jessica henwig as the
main character
l william lee as the mysterious joseph
samira wiley as
lapd recruit ellen davis brian cox as
well as corporation ceo nayendra wallace
senior
josh duamel as blade runner mallow
berghat
abdi as dealer doc badger henry cherny
is medical professor dr m
and many many more the story stretches
over a total of 13 episodes and despite
the most familiar characters you still
cannot really figure out the plot
nevertheless we won't have to wait very
long for further information as blade
runner black lotus will have its own
panel
at this year's virtual san diego
comic-con at the end of the month
last year's comic book adaption the old
guard released on netflix received
mostly positive reviews from fans and
critics alike and was even ranked among
the streaming providers top 10 most
watched films
in an interview with variety leading
actress charlize theron has now revealed
that shooting for the sequel is already
planned to begin in early 2022.
she also confirmed the comeback of the
couple joe and nicki who will be played
by marvin cansari and luca marinelli
part 2 script was lead written by
greg rucka and is even set to be
completed while gina prince bathwat is
back in charge of directing
she already announced quite some time
ago that she found the approach of the
comics to be brilliant and that she
would like to keep her scripts close to
the original
well not a bad idea after all greg rucka
is not
only the screenwriter but also the
author of the comics of the same name
we're looking forward to next year's
shooting as well as an exciting sequel
about the
almost immortal warriors the mcu has
many enemies
dc martin scorsese francis ford coppola
and above all toys the latter in
particular has ensured that fans around
the globe are now aware of peter
parker's new suit
a returning character and a scene from
the upcoming film
so those of you who do not wish to be
spoiled regarding the aforementioned
things
should skip this news now the leak is
about a lego set that features the
protagonists in dr strange's sanctum
sanctorum
besides mj and spider-man you can also
of course recognize doctor strange as
well as
wong it was sort of obvious that strange
would appear in the upcoming film
but we're also looking forward to at
least a brief appearance by one the
scenery on the lego packaging where you
can see wong in the claws of a strange
creature
could indicate an appearance of scorpion
as was already teased in the credits
after spiderman homecoming
since all this information which should
not have come to light has now been
leaked marvel
themselves stepped up and revealed the
official pop figures from funko on their
website
the figure of spider-man is particularly
meaningful as apparently the friendly
neighborhood spider can't perform
magic and no way home at least that's
what the two spheres on his suit suggest
which are strongly reminiscent of doctor
strange in terms of design
the latter of course also gets his own
figure although it raises a few more
questions
doctor strange is seen holding a strange
shovel which we really haven't figured
out yet why
also in funko's lineup is a red and
black spider-man figure
and a blackened gold figure likewise
hasbro is rolling out some new toys
and those are interesting to look at as
well in addition to doctor strange and j
john jameson we also see new spider-man
suits here
one is black with light gold tones and
will presumably be used in the fight
against vulture
another one from hasbro is the red and
gold one and it's almost certainly
spider-man's main suit and no way home
it looks a bit like a cross between the
suit peter tailored in four from home
using his portable workbench
and the iron spider suit especially the
big golden logo on the chest is pretty
close to the iron spider logo from the
comics
quite a lot of input but since both
hasbro and funko have a black and gold
and the red and black suit in their
respective toys chances are that we can
look forward to an appearance of both
outfits about the first trailer for
spider-man no way home which really
can't be long in coming and we are
eagerly awaiting the release date of
december 17th
2021 the netflix blockbuster army of the
dead has barely been released but there
is new material on the prequel already
as you can guess from the title zombies
don't play a role in this movie
instead the story of the german
safecracker ludwig dieter will be told
leading actor matthias schweikova who
already starred in army of the dead not
only plays ludwig dieter
he also serves as the director what the
activities look like in front of the
camera can be seen in five pictures
which not only show the main character
but also the five-person ensemble of
thieves
in addition to schweicher for the cast
also includes jonathan cohn
nathalie emmanuel ruby of faye ghazkan
dirt martin and naomi nakai
according to netflix the film is even
set to be released soon but the
streaming giant has not yet revealed the
exact
date zack snyder can hardly come to rest
lately
after his success with justice league
snydercat and the zombie blockbuster
army of the dead he is now not only
producing army of thieves but on top of
that he's working on his new netflix
project rebel moon
the new movie doesn't have a lot to do
with zombies or superheroes anymore
instead it goes
high up in fact it goes very high up
because rebel moon is about a peaceful
colony on the outer reaches of our
galaxy that has been terrorized by the
villain belisarius
the only salvation for the defenseless
people seems to be a young woman with a
mysterious past and so they send her out
to recruit militant support on the
neighboring planet
director and producer schneider not only
contributes to the script himself but he
also calls in his old companions
shea hat and kurt johnstad the former
also worked on the screenplay of army of
the dead while johnsted collaborate on
the classic 300
shooting is scheduled to begin
relatively soon following the completion
of the script at the beginning of next
year
keanu reeves is currently shooting the
4th john wick movie in berlin
now the british schindler's list actor
liam neeson is also in the german
capital city
the now 69 year old is currently
shooting his thriller retribution at
studio bobblesburg
in terms of content the film is a remake
of the spanish thriller el des conocido
which was released in 2015.
as the main character nissan plays a
banker living in berlin who is suddenly
notified by a mysterious caller that
there is a bomb in his car
in order to save his children who are
sitting in the car also he must raise a
huge sum of money on short notice and
that before the bomb goes off
also starring her stranger things are
matthew modine
and succession actor aryan moyet among
others
in terms of content the story is
somewhat reminiscent of the 1994 film
speed where due to ransom demand the
protagonists also have to drive ford
life in a public bus that is loaded with
a bomb
in any case we are looking forward to
liam neeson's retribution
hopefully the release date will be
announced soon
the video game franchise the last of us
from naughty dog has been one of the
most important
and best titles of two console
generations since its release
fans of the games are all the more
excited about the upcoming hbo series
about joel and ellie
filming began a few days ago and
appropriately enough there is a first
peek at the cast
you can see pedro pascal is the main
character joel gabriel luna as his
brother tommy
and the newly added nico parker as
joel's daughter sarah
naturally this constellation and
especially tommy's car setting
immediately bring traumatic scenes to
the minds of video game veterans as
similar scenes are also played out at
the beginning of the first
the last of us part in the prologue joel
tommy and sarah try to escape from the
newly emerging mushroom epidemic and in
doing so they make their way to the city
in tommy's car
we do not want to spoil what happens
after that but just so you know
there will hardly be a dry eye left
unfortunately we can't give you any
details about the start of the hbo
series yet but a release before the
beginning of 2023
is unlikely given that shooting will
take more than a year
[Music]